et un petit gardien qui accueille ma
joueuse manuela
musique douce et décors oniriques
personnages pleins d'humour c'est dofus
loin très loin du jeu vidéo américain
aux coréens en 3d plus violents et c'est
rio à la base c'est un oeuf à 9 magique
qu'on doit retrouver pour donc augmenter
ses capacités ses pouvoirs dans le jeu
en fait le dofus est représenté par un à
neuf magique en fait et ça marche le jeu
en ligne lancé par une petite équipe
tourquennoise il ya un an a déjà vingt
mille adeptes réguliers abonnés car
accro à ce mélange à cheval entre la bd
le jeu de rôle et la causerie le chat
tout ça dans la peau d'un personnage
dont on choisit le sexe ni couleur et
les caractéristiques ensuite vous allez
effectivement réalisé des aventures
visiter le monde d'amakna qui est le
monde de dofus vous allez rencontrer
d'autres internautes d'autres joueurs et
vous allez discuter avec eux elle allait
réaliser des quêtes à les trouver comme
disait vincent tout à l'heure les eaux
de dragon magique que sont les dofus
voilà faire faire ce que l'objectif du
jeu c'est à dire vous divertir sans
cesse
[Musique]
il ya des joueurs qui ont 11 ans qui
joue à dofus et qui s'y amuser puis à
d'autres joueurs qui ont une
cinquantaine d'années et qui trouvent
aussi leur compte qu'ils s'y amuse
également les eaux magiques ça amuse
encore les quinquagénaires mouais je
pense la preuve ils étaient trois
créateurs sont aujourd'hui trente
salariés et embauchent alors que la
version en anglais de dofus sort cette
semaine le géant lego a même commandé
son nouveau jeu au petit poucet
tourquennois
nationalisation en train d'aimer et un
ange
franck fait partie d un million cinq
cent mille inscrits sur le site dofus
depuis un an et demi franck alias et
l'oeil fréquentes anges et démons tout
un univers virtuel n'est dans cette
entreprise la société ankama 50 employés
en 2000 à ils n'étaient que trois autant
dire que dofus a fait un carton et ce
n'est pas fini chaque jour 5000
personnes s'inscrivent sur le site plat
actuellement ils sont ont créé des
personnages puisque notre jeu c'est un
jeu qui évolue ou régulièrement la porte
des nouveaux contenus donc
aujourd'hui en gros dofus et un bon
millier de personnes âgées il y en aura
encore d'autres dans les mois à venir
petite visite de l'entreprise donc ici
c'est là on réalise dofus-arena douce
arena c'est notre prochain jeu
c'est un jeu tactique comme dofus par
contre ça se base exclusivement sur les
combats des tournois seront même
organisées à paris et à lille c'est un
peu les chic et moderne c'est le
cavalier là aussi des et il aurait par
exemple des coups des coups avec une
épée qui pourrait porter à plusieurs
cases de distance c'est exactement ça
mais surprise la pièce voisine est
consacrée aux bd car ankama a été créée
par des dessinateurs là encore le succès
pointe son nez les premiers mangas se
sont vendues à 15000 exemplaires sortis
cette semaine muta fut case une bd et
noir et déjanté créées par un designer
qui a travaillé pour adidas une mine de
talents et des projets à l'étranger
l'entreprise déménage en octobre pour
7000 m² de bureaux on dira qu ankama est
au pays des merveilles
[Musique]